we've returned to the jungles of
southern Belize where the Jaguar rules
the night once the ancient Maya's
believed that stars were spots on a big
cats coat at one with the evening sky as
its stalked through the shadows tonight
this fierce proud hunter is stalking a
young crocodile
the Jaguar is the largest and most
powerful cat in the Western Hemisphere
and third-largest overall only lions and
tigers are bigger Jaguars are
comfortable in the water in fact they're
one of the few cats who enjoy water the
average male Jaguar weighs 200 pounds
and lives 12 to 15 years in the wild
it's an endangered species mainly
because of the skin trade and habitat
destruction this Jaguar is displaying a
lethal self-confidence as it fishes for
croc not much question who's going to
win this battle
time to close the deal
it's not hard to see how the Jaguar got
its name
it's from the Guarani Indian word yeah
Guara meaning beast that captures its
prey in a single bound